Hey,
wise,
crack jared again.
Today we're talking about a film that
everyone's loving and nobody's watching.
Blade runner 20,
49.
The central question,
the original blade runner poses is what
makes us human.
The cul continues to meditate on the
importance of this question,
but instead of retreading the same
brown,
it proposes something new that is
essential to our humanity and how does
it do this with holographic?
Why foods and weird avant garde
literature.
Welcome list wise,
crack quick.
Take our blade runner.
20,
49.
Major spoilers ahead.
First,
a recap.
After the events of the original blade
runner,
the world freaked out and banned the
production of replicants.
However,
tensions eventually cool and a new
company starts to produce replicants
that to quote Rick Sanchez has zero
chance of going blade runner 20,
49 follows k,
a replicant hunting blade runner and
replicant himself.
He discovers the skeleton of a replicant
that shows signs of having given birth,
which should be impossible.
K sent in search of the trial replicant
and discovers the father is a certain Mr
Decker,
informed by a childhood memory case,
suspects that he is deckards miracle
child that would start the replicant
revolution except ease,
not the memory was implanted by deckards
real daughter,
confined the reunites with her mean old
ad.
The 1982 classic largely reflects on how
attachment to memories both for mankind
and replicants defines our humanity
replicants,
recite poetry and ask all the
philosophical questions while we're
shown debase humans who are all drunk
and disease.
All this serves to further blur the
distinction between human and replicant.
Twenty,
49 explores this fuzzy,
replicant human distinction in another
way with intimacy and physical
connection or rather the lack of it.
The only real relationship k experiences
is with his holographic girlfriend.
Joy K tries to make their relationship
more real by uploading her to a portable
projector,
allowing her to free roam in one of the
weirder scenes,
joy projects her image onto a prostitute
so they can physically touch.
The desire for intimacy is subtly
implanted all throughout the film.
Neander wallace,
the creator of the new replicants,
must feel and touch everything due to
his blindness.
Deckards daughter is locked in an
isolation chamber and unable to touch
the holograms that keep her entertained.
There's also a recurring motif of
feeling precipitation,
as I'll call it.
Joy going outside for the first time
reaches out to feel the rain,
but it goes right through her replicants
wear gloves all throughout the film
until k removes his own to feel the
touch of falling snow earlier.
Case outstretched hand is covered in
bees,
although to be honest,
I'm a little less sure about what the
bees represent.
We also see a group of orphans
collectively touch k when he shows up to
find the replicant.
Child and Hologram Elvis sings,
take my hand from his song,
can't help falling in love after deckerd
in KP,
the hell out of each other.
The film's shot shows decker trying to
touch his daughter,
but they're obstructed by a glass wall.
Through this,
the importance of touch and connection
is seen as innately human.
The second way,
20,
49 explores the human replicant
distinction is in its exploration of how
memory builds our personal narrative and
how fallible that is.
See,
this is really interesting because
whereas the original blade runner showed
replicants making claims to humanity
with memories.
20,
49 goes further.
Implying memories alone aren't enough.
You might remember the bizarre
post-trauma stress test k has to go
through twice.
He sits in a barren room where a
disembodied voice keeps saying stuff
about a system of cells while k responds
with words like interlinked cells and
dreadfully.
This test has ripped straight from
Vladimir Nabokov,
book Pale Fire.
The full excerpt is a system of cells
interlinked within cells,
interlinked within one step and
dreadfully distinct against the dark.
A Tall White Fountain played later.
We actually see Pale fire in k's
apartment.
Enjoy,
asked him to read it.
The premise of Pale fire is essentially
that you've got a poem by a fictional
author being analyzed in the footnotes
by a fictional commentator.
It's a book about a commentary about a
poem.
Essentially books,
the whole cells interlinked.
Passage details are fictional poet.
Having a heart attack and seeing a
vision of a tall white fountain.
Later in the poem he reads about someone
else having a near death experience and
seeing the same white fountain convinced
that this shared vision proves the
existence of an afterlife.
The poet investigates further only to
discover the line was a misprint and the
person actually said White Mountain
sensing a theme here.
These narratives that we build around
objects and memories is at the heart of
20,
49 discussion on what makes a human case
memory of a wooden horse leads him to
believe that he is this miracle child,
but surprise he isn't.
They're not his memories,
their implants.
Just as the fictional poet of Pale
fires,
revelation is shattered after realizing
the white fountain was a misprint.
Kay's revelation is shattered after
realizing beat miss imprint of a memory,
and this is where the themes of intimacy
and memory combined when he's given the
choice to help the resistance by killing
deckerd,
he refuses.
Instead of trusting his memories,
he puts his faith in the intimacy and
physical connection he yearns for.
Thus,
he lets this not memory guide him to his
decision to reunite deckerd and his
daughter and just like the original
blade runner,
a replicant disobeys,
his programming to save a life,
thus achieving meaning and maybe even a
soul.
There is so much more we could say about
the thematic connections between 20,
49 and pale fire like parental loss,
the need for memorial or even just the
line father time.
All gray and bent emerged with is uneasy
dog,
which sounds lot like deckerd and his
furry companion plus what's up with all
the water imagery,
the cell imagery there a lot more to
unpack here,
so let us know what you think in the
comments and maybe we'll do an earthling
cinema or a true philosophy up until
next time.
Thanks for watching.
Peace.
Wise crack.
If you want to dive further into blade
runner 20,
49,
you should definitely hit up our
friends,
Eric and Philip over at the new
rockstars channel.
Think of a movie show or trailer that
you've seen.
All right.
You got it.
Well,
they've definitely analyzed it.
They've got an awesome video on the
soundtrack of baby driver that breaks
down how Edgar Wright creates an action
musical.
They've also got some really cool videos
analyzing the movie it and breakdowns of
every single episode of this past season
of game of thrones,
and if you're into all the stuff we've
been making in want to help us do more,
consider becoming a patron.
We've got a growing library of patron
only content,
including the legendary,
too hot for Youtube,
eight bit philosophy video podcast on
wonder woman and the Matrix evolutions,
a new video on the movie it and more.
We're working on more patron exclusives
each month,
like early access to upcoming videos.
Quick takes and much more.
So check out our patrion page by
clicking here and don't forget to check
out new rockstars with these links here.
Until next time,
guys,
peace.